este cuarto día de asamblea
solidaridad nacional
multilateralismo frente a
pandemia luego escucha mover lo discutido
pre travato del papa francisco aunque
comete claro aunque subas genera
el sabor cuando se completa en cinco años
de su visita a la sede de la acción asm
su se unirá sabe quién es nuevo si espera que el
Papa estas vez a un té discutido
solidaridad conjunta
la especia y los brotes hacen frente a
espectáculo de molestia pandémica al completo
presidente le españa pedro sanchez che
porter e porter sera a su interviene
cuerpo y que como marca van a esperar el
el centro de su discurso es la pandemia y
a las masas le pediremos disculpas al presidente el
palestino macuto que augusto tra era un
maderas temáticas en el número del envío smas
antiguas tenencia y el organismo y ungüento
encina a la libre determinación de
Pollo arabe pero se pone gordo en esto pero
comienzo soy independiente de leocour con
extendido dijo la samp la general de
Naciones Unidas